quelle serait pour vous la définition
d'une bonne table une bonne table bon
deux bans un plateau et puis deux pieds
ça suffit voilà c'est ma table
idéale choisiriez-vous un restaurant en
fonction du nombre de fourchettes
monsieur non je ne pense pas ça
indispensable d'avoir plusieurs couteaux
plusieurs fourchotes mais enfin il faut
il faut quand même avoir le minimum pour
pour pouvoir manger quoi que pensez-vous
madame de la réserve du patron je pense
que c'est nécessaire auprès de ses
clients les clients apprécient un patron
réservé plutôt qu' patron qui est tué à
toi et qui qui ne cesse de les ennuyer
tout le long du repas qu'appelle-t-on à
mitron madame bah un mitron c'est une
personne qui est assis qu'on voit que le
Tron par exemple Christine ou Patrick
qui sont Christine et Patrick c'est des
journalistes à la télévision le trou
normand un petit village
entre flair et denfont Le
Châtelier qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire
ça c'est un trou il y a pas plus de 50
habitants on y est bien appréciez-vous
les crudités au
restaurant non non parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est les crudité bah c'est par
exemple des gens qui sont mal polis
envers les sererveuses qui font des gàes
déplacés enfin moi j'étais serveuse dans
quatre restaurants différents et puis
bah ça m'est jamais arrivé de de que les
gens soi soi cru avec moi le canard
laquéis qu'est-ce que c'est canard laqu
donc c'est un canard qui vit sur les
lacs canard sauvage en fait un grand
traiteur un grand traiteur alors c'est
un quelqu'un qui traite les gens de de
tous les noms quelle serait pour vous la
définition d'une bonne table une bonne
table bon de Ban un plateau et puis de
pieds ça suffit voilà c'est ma table
idéale êtesvous une disciple d'Épicure
madame ou oui j'en ai pas peur
disonsp ça fait pas peur d'en avoir
peut-on dire que vous avez du palais
madame non non non non non certainement
pas non on a simplement appartement
c'est tout en ville ancien c'est tout
que pensez-vous de la bonne chair la
bonne chair si c'est une bonne à plein
de temps comme je vous l'explique je
trouve que c'est quand même très très
cher les charges sociales sont très
élevées et c'est pratiquement maintenant
impossible d'avoir une bonne à plein
temps comme on pouvait avoir
[Musique]
autrefois